[Music]
miami held its first formula one rates
over the weekend and of course las vegas
will be hosting ours in about 18 months
time everybody was talking about it over
the weekend now ron futrell joins us
live in studio with
some new developments on the vegas race
ron yes indeed christian kirsten
november 2023 is the target date for the
saturday night race along the las vegas
strip but there is a property just east
of the strip that is the focus today
liberty media the group that owns
formula one is in a deal to buy 39 acres
along koval road not much to look at now
it's just east of the strip it's
believed this is the area where f1 will
build a garage area for the cars and the
teams
they talked to me early on before they
put the money down and bought the land
they need a big footprint in order to do
stuff and i'm thrilled because i think
that extends their commitment further
out then they're already committed for
it to buy put 250 million dollars in a
piece of dirt is a pretty solid
commitment and they're excited about
being here we have regular
communications and
i'm looking forward to we're going to be
a lot better than it is in miami or
austin i can guarantee you that oh it's
game on okay the miami grand prix was a
success over the weekend first f1 race
in miami everything went well
now the lot near the corner of koval and
harmon you see the ice right there
it sold for the 240 million dollar price
but this is expected to be the permanent
site for the garage area the grandstands
and the start finish line now they could
do more with that property because it's
also zoned for casino use ellis island
is close by so they'll have a front row
so it will be nice to see that large
empty lot near the strip being used for
something other than dust storms i'm ron
futrell live local now